[Musique]
totti
lorsqu'une fille me plaisait je la taper
ça vous est déjà arrivé
ça a duré sous différentes formes
charriage insultes et voir blague de
mauvais goût
de mon côté petit pour se faire des amis
il fallait faire ses preuves
il fallait montrer qu'on savait se
battre
ado nos grands jeux autre que le foot
avec les copains c'était de courir à
toute allure dans la cour de récré de
soulever les jupes des filles voire de
leur mettre une main aux fesses
adolescent je ne vivais que pour le
vous l'avez compris pour moi
c'était les lions indomptables du
cameroun
et vous savez sur le terrain il faut
être agressif parce qu on nous répétait
sans cesse le foot n'est pas un sport de
danseuses
zulte combien de fois il m'est arrivé
d'avoir des regrets après avoir consommé
l'amour avec une femme
vous savez comme moi qu'un homme qui a
plusieurs bureaux à lomé
quand je parle de bureau vous voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est un don juan
un casanova impuissant un vent un bon
amant
de l'autre côté
pour une femme c'est une fille facile
légère de mauvaises fortunes voire même
une prostituée alors vous avez été amusé
peut-être un peu choqué
mais finalement cette anecdote on est
nombreux à les partager
elles sont le reflet de notre éducation
de garçon dans un monde d'hommes
je m'appelle william djabou du français
banlieusards mais à neuilly sur seine
mais comme on m'indique les ancêtres ne
sont pas gaulois ils sont bantous
je suis le dernier d'une fratrie de
quatre qu'on aurait appelé sororité si
je n'étais pas né
vous l'avez compris j'ai trois grandes
serres
le fils de mon histoire commence par
celle de mes parents originaires du
cameroun et qui ont émigré vers 2 qui
ont émigré vers la france dans les
années 70 pour y faire leurs études
mon enfance a été bercée par un savant
mélange
entre mes racines camerounaise bamiléké
et ma culture française
l'adolescent ça a été pour moi une
période de questionnement
une période de questionnement pas tant
sur ce tueur qui j'étais mais sur ce que
je représente est aux yeux des autres
le sensible comme le sentiment qu'à
société remet en question tout ce que tu
penses être entre contrôles d'identité
incessants propositions d'orientation
scolaire biaisé
ou encore les masques qu'on doit porter
sans cesse à l'école aux quartiers à la
maison et toutes ces expériences qui ont
fait de moi un homme
je m'appelle bolewa sabourin
je suis né d'une mère française
d'origine gauloise
et d'un père congolais dans tous nos
maux
à un an mon père m'en vois à kinshasa
vivre avec mes grands parents dans la
vie de ma mère
on est d'accord il me kidnappe j'y
resterai cinq ans les cinq plus belles
années de ma vie
six ans
à paris
je découvre l'école
et le français moi qui ne parlait que le
lingala
j apprends que le mot con que l'on dit
si souvent dans la cour de récré
veut dire texte féminin
que nique ta mère veut dire avoir des
relations incestueuses avec sa maman
dès l'époque où l'on me trimballe du
paris bourgeois
populaire de saint-denis l'atteinte du
5e arrondissement
onze ans
retrouvailles avec maman perdu dix ans
auparavant
un suivi son homme de l'époque en
martinique
absence est source de conflit entre nous
t'aimons 7e déménagement cinquième
établissement scolaire et troisième
continent en six ans
la danse que je commence à pratiquer
assidûment sera ma bouée de sauvetage
face à autant d'instabilité
pratique
man maîtrisé
mais deux échecs successifs au bac alors
aucune partie de ma vie j'ai un métier
dans les pieds jeu de danse
et prend des cours à smoking et
brillantine où je rencontre william
oui c'est le moment de notre rencontre
très vite on s'est retrouvé autour de
valeurs communes autour d'une idée
consommé de la danse
on avait la volonté de sortir de
l'aspect purement contemplatif de la
danse
partir de l'aspect purement divertissant
de la danse les stéréotypes aussi qu'on
peut représenter parce que la danse
était pour nous un espace d'expression
un espace de liberté et surtout on a
compris que la danse pouvait être un
outil d'engagement
qu'est ce qui nous a poussé à organiser
des événements qui nous ressemble et en
s'appuyant d'abord sur la danse puis sur
les autres formes d'art
nous vivons dans des monde sécularisé où
nous êtres hybrides
nous nous y retrouvons pas nous voulons
retrouver
bourgeois nos banlieusards
nos noir noblanc nous maghrébins nos
assiettes no1 indien
par des hommes des enfants des jeunes et
des moins jeunes
bref nous voulons recréer un monde où
toute personne peut se rassembler
t'exprimer selon sa singularité
selon son art
c'est la raison pour laquelle en 2007 on
a créé le bas
dire exprime toi en lingala
un seul mot d'ordre l'art au service de
la cité
durant ces années là bas nous avons
continué de nous former
benoît vous voyez là obtenu brillamment
son master en sciences politiques et en
ingénierie de la concertation
je l'appelle et de mon côté j'ai obtenu
mon doctorat en sciences économiques et
donc parallèlement à ça on a continué de
se former on a fait des formations
concernant l'entrepreneuriat social
on a fait iech week-end est porté
notamment par l'ambassade des états unis
tickets de fortes yens ce qui est un
tour de france de l'entrepreneuriat
social tout autant de nouvelles cordes à
notre arc qui nous ont permis d'entamer
le tournage allait prendre notre
association
notre combat en mars 2016 je rencontre
le docteur denis mukwege gynécologue
obstétricien de docteur répare des
femmes qui ont été victimes de viol
comme arme de guerre
à l'est du congo
et puis
mais en 2018
tu es viol
spitz
dans le fruit d'une guerre pour le
sous-sol congolais qui permettent la
révolution numérique
les femmes sont violées afin de faire
fuir la population et ainsi exploiter le
sous-sol congolais
femme à qui n'ont introduit des
kalachnikov des machettes et autres
objets contendants dans le vagin sont
réparés par le docteur et ses équipes
mais vous imaginez bien que la
réparation physique ne suffit pas qu'il
faut réparer la psyché le docteur hong
kong et nous dit que la psychothérapie
occidental ne fonctionne que très peu
avec ces femmes
que raconter son histoire en tête à tête
avec un professionnel ou une
professionnelle ne se fait pas
culturellement
mais que par la danse et le chant cela
fonctionne beaucoup plus facilement
je lui demande
comment je peux me rendre utile je ne
suis ni médecin ni politicien mais
qu'avec mes compétences je veux
participer à ce combat que je trouve
primordial et jean par la williams
le projet recréation a vu le jour lors
d'un séjour à bukavu au congo dans la
fondation points 10 du docteur beaucoup
aidé
notre objectif permettre à ces femmes de
parler par la danse et ainsi entamé un
processus de réparation psychique pas
d'expression de leurs trauma ces
horreurs et nous avons entendu
et quand je vous partage là
tous
les vous
l'engouement qu'a eu nos ateliers de
danse nous ont poussés à voir ce projet
de manière plus durable plus pérenne
on s'est senti donc la responsabilité de
se transformer loba devait évoluer en
entreprise d'économie sociale et
solidaire pour pouvoir soutenir sur le
long terme des femmes victimes de ces
hohrod de ces horreurs de ces atrocités
pour notre confort mais aussi pour ces
femmes qui souffrent de la domination
masculine re création est une thérapie
innovante qui allie le travail d'un
binôme danseurs danseuses et
psychothérapeute
pour la prise en charge d'un groupe de
femmes
tu es une alliance pour la prise en
charge du corps et d'esprit et l'esprit
excusez moi sans hiérarchisation
re création c'est aussi une compagnie de
danse qui allie la danse et le théâtre
pour raconter ces femmes avec qui on
travaille et sensibiliser le grand
public à ces questions
tu es aussi une méthodologie de
pédagogie active en direction des plus
jeunes afin de les sensibiliser les
mobiliser pour les violences faites aux
femmes
mais lorsque nous avons fait tout cela
avons toujours pas résolu le problème
nous vidons la mer avec une petite
cuillère sans jamais s'attaquer aux
causes
finalement quelle est la cause profonde
de ces violences
de ces horreurs de ces morts
il ya près de trente ans maintenant le 8
mars 1987 thomas sankara
exprimé sur la question de la domination
masculine et des effets que cette
domination masculine avait sur la
société
premier temps il exprime le fait que la
transformation des mentalités ne peut
être qu'elle complète si la femme de
type nouveau doivent vivre avec un homme
de type ancien par ailleurs il ajoute
un homme s'ils ont pris mes soit il
trouve toujours un être à oppresser
hamon
la violence de la domination masculine
exerce pour ceux qui la subissent
mais également sur ceux qui la font
subir
domination masculine pose la question 2
qu'est ce qu'être un homme qu'est ce
qu'un homme peut on prend le
dictionnaire
finalement un homme c'est un individu de
sexe masculin
jusque-là ça paraît trivial
nous renvoie donc à la définition de la
masculinité
masculinité un ensemble d'attributs de
comportement et de rôle associé aux
garçons et aux hommes
donc finalement la masculinité c'est une
construction sociale
être un homme ce n'est pas ce que l'on
met mais ce qu'on est supposé être
dans nos sociétés
être un homme sait répondre aux
injonctions d'une masculinité le culte
de la virilité une à mal transmis comme
une norme
lee un rapport à la puissance à la
domination à l'invulnérabilité au
contrôle de nos émotions
tu es ce mal qui pour nous est à la
source des maux de nos sociétés
l'urgence climatique
pensez de vouloir toujours dominé terre
qui nous a été offerte
les crises économiques
que des hommes dans des bureaux qui font
échouer nos économies et qui malgré les
échecs continuer à diriger nos économies
[Musique]
avec ce principe de too big to fail too
big to fail l'invulnérabilité le
sentiment de pouvoir causer un ensemble
de dégâts économiques et sociaux sans
avoir à répondre de ses actes nos
politiques
voyez ces dernières années nous vivons
une crise mondiale et où la réponse
globale c'est de mettre des hommes qui
reflète le mâle alpha dominant qui
reprendrait le pouvoir
donald trump
ben laden de vladimir poutine jean ping
boris johnson et on en connaît encore
bien d'autres dans nos contrées on veut
pouvoir sortir de l'hiver dans les bars
[Applaudissements]
belges
il est temps il est temps maintenant ici
de la terre mère il est temps de passer
à l'étape suivante
tels de la re création c'est d'ailleurs
l'objet de notre dernier projet où l'on
propose aux hommes de se re questionner
entre eux afin de libérer la parole
harly tholot bas tout est honni de nos
vulnérabilités
parce que se parler tu es déjà de la
transgression
c'est bravé l'interdît
le mythe le mythe de l'inde il n'est
habilité ce mythe qui nous fait tant
souffrir et souffrir l'humanité ainsi
que la planète
alors aujourd'hui
j'ai vous passez à cet enjeux
civilisationnels parler exprimez vous
échanger avec vos amis vos collègues en
famille sur les causes profondes de ce
problème
d'ailleurs là maintenant tout de suite
prenez deux minutes on vous demande du
deux minutes de votre temps et posez
vous une petite question une petite
question simple question
qu'est ce qu'être un homme au 21ème
siècle à votre voisin ou voisines
allez-y alesi a les yeux
poser la question c'est la porte
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent sommes au
21ème siècle
vous voulez excusez moi vous voyez se
poser la question c'est déjà le début de
la solution
on vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
le